MALE SPEAKER: OK, so this
morning, Brady sent me an
email, and he said, check this
out-- something has happened.
And so, on Sunday, it
was the Super Bowl.
I didn't know that myself.
I think Brady-- did you know
it was the Super Bowl?
BRADY HARAN: Yes, I stayed
up and watched it.
I love the Super Bowl.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, OK, OK.
Apparently, we have
two conferences.
We've got the NFC, National
Football Conference.
We've got the AFC, the American
And so every year they have a
team from each conference, and
they play the Super Bowl.
OK.
So for the last 14 years-- the
previous 14 years-- the team
that represents the NFC have
won the coin toss.
Well, it's certainly,
certainly a
really unlikely event.
Now unlikely events happen.
So last Sunday, this winning
streak of 14 wins that they
had so far was broken.
So last Sunday, it was the AFC,
the team that represented
the AFC, was it the Patriots?
The Patriots won
the coin toss.
So that's breaking our streak
of 14 successive wins.
BRADY HARAN: They then did
lose the game, though.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, that's
a shame isn't it?
Never mind.
OK, yeah, enough of this
football stuff.
Right, let's do some maths.
Right, so we're going to work
out how long it would take to
get that streak of
14 in a row.
14 wins in a row.
Right?
So to make this a bit easier,
we're not just going to dive
into the full thing.
We're not going to work
out 14 wins in a row.
We'll make this a bit easier.
We're going to look at getting
3 wins in a row.
If we can work this out,
if we can understand
it, the rest is easy.
Let's work out how long
it would take to
get 3 wins in a row.
OK.
So this is the odds of winning
the coin toss,
not the game, no.
I could see Brady doing this.
I thought he was giving
me the thumbs-up.
He was like, yeah, good.
Right.
What I want to look at first
is-- let's look at getting 3
wins or winning 3 coin
tosses in a row.
OK, so first of all, what's
the probability of getting
those 3 wins?
This is quite easy.
I think a lot of people can
do this themselves.
We're looking for
3 wins in a row.
A win--
a probability of winning
the coin toss is 1/2.
So, to win one time, is 1/2.
To win again, you times
it by 1/2 again.
And then to win 3 times,
you times by 1/2.
OK.
So 1/8 of the time, you could
win 3 coin tosses.
What about a streak of
4, a sequence of 4.
Because that means you've lost
and then you've won 1.
So it's loss, win, win, win.
Now what's the probability
of that?
Again, not too hard
to work out.
1/2, 1/2, 1/2, 1/2, 1/16.
1/16 of the time you're going
to get a sequence of 4 games
that ends with win, win, win.
Or 4 coin tosses.
So what we're going to work out
is the average sequence--
the length of the average
sequence that ends
with win, win, win.
What if it was a sequence
that was 5?
That means it could be like
loss, loss, then ends with
win, win, win.
Or you could have a win, then
a loss, win, win, win.
For each of those, the
probability is 1/32.
But there's 2 of them, so
altogether, if your sequence
is 5 games long, it's
2 out of 32.
So if you want to work out the
probability of the average
sequence length, what
you do is you take
the sequence lengths--
each situation-- and multiply
them by the probability of
getting that situation.
Now this is our waiting time.
This is how long we want to wait
for our win, win, win.
It looks like you would have
to work out every single
possible situation, every
possible probability for that
situation, multiply
them all together.
That would give you
your average.
That would include all possible
situations like win,
win, loss, loss,
win, win, win.
Then it would be win, loss,
win, loss, win,
loss, win, win, win.
So every single possible
situation.
And that does not
sound like fun.
So there's a really clever
way to do this, and
this is really clever.
Right.
I'll show you how to do this.
I'm going to draw you a little
picture for this.
So let's say you lose
here and then win.
Or lose and win.
Or lose here and win.
OK, I've drawn you
a little picture.
So the probability of losing is
1/2, losing your coin toss.
Probability of winning
the coin toss is 1/2.
Let's say we're looking for the
time we have to wait to
get these 3 wins in a row.
This call that t.
Now in the first case,
I can toss my coin.
And if I lose, I'm back
to square one.
I've tossed a coin, and then I'm
back-- oh, I have to do it
all over again.
So the length of
that sequence--
I've tossed a coin.
Then I'm back to square one.
Back to square one means
I'm back to this.
I'm back to waiting t games
for my sequence of 3, t.
That's how long I would have
to wait if I lose.
And the probability
of losing is 1/2.
Times it by the probability,
that's what you get.
The other situation is this.
You could win, then lose,
and back to square one.
Win and lose probability
is 1/4.
And then you're back to square
one, where you've tossed it
once, you've tossed the coin
twice, and then you're back to
square one.
That means you have
to wait t again.
That's how many games
you have to wait.
Or the third situation
is you win, you win,
and then you lose.
And you're back to square one.
So what's the probability
of that happening?
That's 1/8, then 3 coin tosses,
back to square one,
means 3 plus t.
Or, and the final situation is
you get it straight away--
win, win, win.
And the probability
of that is 1/8.
And how long did
I have to wait?
3 coin tosses, win, win, win.
And you've got your
3 wins in a row.
Fantastic.
You solve this.
This is what you do.
You solve this formula.
It's not that hard to solve,
you just multiply that out,
mess around with it.
I can tell you, if you
do you solve it, the
answer is t equals 14.
This is the average length that
you would have to wait,
the average number of games you
would have to wait to get
3 wins in a row.
Now if you want to do it in
general, if you want to do it
for 14, pretty much
the same idea.
The same idea.
But in general, you get this.
T is equal to 2 to the power
n plus 1, minus 2.
That is the amount of time you
would have to wait to get n
wins in a row, n wins.
N is going to be 14 for
the Super Bowl.
In the Super Bowl, it was 14.
So if n equals 14, we're
going to use this.
And I can tell you the answer.
It was--
32,766.
We would have to play 32,766
games before-- well, that's
the average anyway.
Before you could expect to
get 14 wins in a row.
That's the average, I mean maybe
it would take longer.
Maybe you'll get it
straight away.
We don't know.
But on average, it's going
to be about 32,000 games.
Maybe 32,000 years.
BRADY HARAN: It only took 45
Super Bowls for them to get 14
coin tosses in a row, though.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah it did.
BRADY HARAN: What happened?
MALE SPEAKER: So unlikely
events can happen.
Unlikely events like
this can happen.
And like I said before, we can
toss as many coins as we want.
It's not impossible.
It's just unlikely.
So this isn't a probability.
What I've worked out isn't
a probability.
This isn't the probability of
winning 14 times in a row.
This is the length of time that
we're going to wait, the
number of games we're
going to play.
Or the number of coin tosses
we're going to do until we get
14 wins in a row.
And it's the average number.
And in the case of the Super
Bowl, which happens only once
year, if you want this to happen
again, then, I would
expect to wait 32,000 years--
maybe 32,766 years, even.